[Music]
i've known tarek for 15 years and he
hasn't changed
a bit oh i've known amber for 15 years
and
here are a few of the ways that amber
has changed
number one okay this part of the show is
over
we have to move on you guys it's been a
crazy week in america
let's find out what happened
during a recent interview with oprah
duchess meghan markle revealed that she
and prince harry were secretly married
three days before the royal wedding
which begs the question who was it that
was concerned about how dark his skin
will be
they better make with her name i swear
to goodness how
dark will it
[Music]
um here's something white people don't
know when we're talking about you in
public
we go were they or
yeah it's a little well fun black secret
uh
president biden's 1.9 trillion dollar
stimulus bill arrived this week
in the house of representatives here's a
video of it arriving
it was announced this week that super
nintendo world in japan will open later
this month
if you're interested in getting tickets
here's the link
never have i been prouder of a joke
listen link did you play legend of zelda
i
played uh what was the wind talker
what the [ __ ] are you talking i don't
know
talk to the wind because the face ain't
listening
what are you saying i don't know it was
in a cube
you guys if you have heard of wind
please tweet at tarik there is no such
thing as woodtucker
windtalker is the name of a nicholas
cage movie
what were you thinking of i'm thinking
of th this is something you guys
before this show is over we will be back
to you with the answer we will
saturday was former nba player shaquille
o'neal's 49th birthday
that's right 49 years ago today shaq's
mom had
a day the washington post
published an article about an increase
of so-called
cow cuddling because people cannot hug
loved ones
during the coronavirus pandemic or as it
will soon be known
the coronavirus mad cow disease pandemic
according to a new survey 93 of
americans believe a woman could lead the
country within 10 years
just not that woman or that woman oh i
like her
wait she wants it then no never mind not
her
and finally in a recent report nebraska
was named the sixth best
u.s state to live in but then they found
out my mommy and daddy live there and
they made it number one
mommy daddy number one quit showing
pictures of me on your little show
what's wrong with you and that was the
monologue
hey uh so can i read my list now no
i'm sorry it's just that we're pressed
for time
amber you you don't have an earpiece in
there my thingy told me
you guys as you may have heard dr seuss
enterprises announced last week
that they will stop publishing six dr
seuss books
that show racist imagery so you know
what that means
it's time for another bad faith argument
[Music]
wait so let me get this straight we
can't have dr seuss no more
but those two rapper girls can still
have [ __ ] do you know what that stands
for
yeah so let me get this straight let me
get this straight those two rapper girls
can have wap but
if i use that word as a racial slur i
get fired from the gas station
so let me get this straight let me get
this straight so women can wear whatever
they want but i'm the [ __ ] if i say
i love the way your boobs look your
honor so let me get this straight let me
get this straight
black people can say the n-word but i
can't shout the different ethnicities of
people as they get onto the bus
so let me get this right let me get this
straight people can work a professional
job with a big old
afro and i'm not allowed to hide little
snacks in there
i mean what let me get this straight
genitals don't equal gender but i'm not
allowed to hold on to my ding-dong at
the groceries
let me get this let me get this straight
the bachelor can have a house full of
beautiful women fawning over them
but i attempt to do that and suddenly
i'm the star of a hbo max documentary
about a mediocre cult
well let me get this straight let me get
this straight hot dogs are technically
sandwiches because they got a bun on
both sides but when i say i want to make
a sandwich by putting both sides of a
chick's buns around my face
then i'm asked to step down from the
senate jesus christ let me get this
straight
black people could do all black death of
a salesman but if we want to do an
all-white porgy and bess
we're politically incorrect if we do an
all-white raisin in the sun
we're the bad guys you can do an
all-black death of a salesman
but we can't do it all white the color
purple i mean
now we've covered most of the recent
news but there's one more story i'd like
to talk about
the oklahoma house of representatives
passed a bill recently that allows them
to declare
federal laws unconstitutional when
tarik are you okay oh oh yeah yes my
shoulder
it's feeling a little bit weird i i got
the vaccine this morning
oh my gosh i didn't know that
congratulations for what
it's awful what do you mean that's great
news now you don't have to live in fear
of covid
yeah sure but i also have this annoying
tingle in my arm
and you're upset about it that feels
like a really minor um
a minor you're thinking of the word
interference but what you really mean is
inconvenience
yeah how did you know that
i don't know i've been uh feeling kind
of psychic ever since the vaccine hit
are you telling me you can read minds
now
yeah yeah you know i wish i could have
read that nurse's mind before the
vaccine so i know
my damn shoulder be hurting i can't
believe you're complaining about such a
small problem when you've got the power
to read money
amber we're gonna have to stop down for
a second tarik's podium is out of place
oh oh no worries uh here let me let me
move it
[Music]
you've got to be kidding me what you
have telekinesis too
oh yeah this thing came with all sorts
of weird side effects you know i kind of
wish they
tested a little bit longer you know this
shoulder thing is really annoying
hey amber we're gonna have to stop down
again terex light needs to be adjusted
don't worry i got it oh what the
all right i think it's fixed now so is
this happening for everybody that gets
the vaccine
yeah yeah i think so you know i was
reading online that everybody is getting
the same kind of shoulder pain
shut up about your shoulder that is not
the headline of what's happening here
well well well i see there's a new
superhero in town
what who is this dr archibald crew
mad scientist and superhero killer i
sensed your new
powers and immediately followed you here
to your fortress to murder you
with my death ray kill me good luck
i stand for justice and i'm committed to
doing whatever it takes to defend people
like me
oh tarek who have slightly sore
shoulders
dang it time for you to say good night
i'm
did you have that before or is this also
from the vaccine yeah i knew you were
gonna ask that
vaccine okay so you can read minds
you can make things move telekinetically
you can fly
and you can shoot lasers out of your
eyes that make cartoon super villains
disappear
all of this happened because the vaccine
and yet you don't seem excited about it
at all
why aren't you freaking out oh i'm sorry
i wasn't paying attention this shoulder
pain is really bugging me ah i hate this
stupid vaccine
you mind if i take the rest of the day
off what no we've got a show to do
oh fine
hey look at that i think i fixed it i'm
okay now
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
[Applause]
you